Trascrizione: Robert Tucker
Revisore: Stefania Recchia
Quando ero una bambina pensavo spesso
di voler essere un maschio,
perché nella mia generazione
le ragazze spesso desideravano
essere maschi,
perché le opportunità,
che i maschi avevano,
sembrano decisamente diverse dalle nostre.
I ragazzi potevano studiare,
potevano scegliere la professione
che volevano.
È passato tanto tempo,
ho visto cambiare molte cose.
Facendo lo psicoterapeuta per tanti anni,
ho incontrato ancora ragazze
che mi dicevano
di non essere contente di essere donne,
però sempre meno.
Direi che la generazione di adesso,
le giovani ragazze di adesso,
non hanno questo problema,
sono contente della loro femminilità.
Raramente vengono dicendo:
"Dottoressa il mio problema è
che dovevo nascere maschio".
Eppure, spesso non sono contente
le ragazze.
che dovevo nascere maschio".
Eppure, spesso non sono contente,
le ragazze.
Vedo tante donne, tante ragazze
che arrivano affannate,
scontente, poco serene,
sempre di corsa dietro le cose.
Quindi mi pongo delle domande. Mi dico:
"Ma certo tante cose sono cambiate,
tante cose sono migliorate,
però ancora non stiamo bene.
Cosa succede?"
Mi è tornato in mente
un autore anni Trenta,
una psicoanalista, Winnicott,
che si faceva una domanda:
"Che cosa dà alla persona
la sensazione di essere serena,
di essere piena,
di avere una vita che ha senso
dal punto di vista psicologico?"
e la risposta che Winnicott dava era:
"È la creatività".
La creatività è ciò che dà alla persona
la percezione di una vita che ha senso.
E che cos'è la creatività.
La creatività è la possibilità
di mettere a contatto
qualcosa che nasce dal mondo interno,
da dentro di noi, con il mondo esterno,
quindi è la possibilità, in qualche modo,
di mettere fuori qualcosa che nasce
da dentro di noi.
Questa è la creatività e può essere messa
in atto in tantissimi modi:
nella musica naturalmente, ma anche
in piccole cose di ogni giorno,
anche nella modalità
in cui noi stiamo nel mondo,
nelle relazioni che noi mettiamo in atto.
Pesca dentro di noi quando
noi riusciamo a mettere in atto
un buon contatto con noi stessi,
quindi quando prendiamo
un profondo contatto con noi stessi.
La mia sensazione è che oggi
le donne abbiano perso un po'
la capacità di avere un buon contatto
con se stesse,
perché noi siamo, sì, entrate sempre più
nel mondo del lavoro,
nel mondo degli uomini,
possiamo ricoprire qualsiasi ruolo,
molte disuguaglianze si sono attenuate,
però noi siamo entrate, in gran parte,
nel mondo degli uomini con una modalità
che non è nostra:
siamo entrate nel mondo degli uomini
al maschile.
Molto spesso, quello che io vedo
è che le donne si affannano
a vivere nel mondo del lavoro
e nella vita con una modalità
che non sempre è una modalità femminile.
Non per cattiva volontà, direi in parte
perché il mondo del lavoro lo richiede,
perché il mondo ce lo chiede;
in parte perché forse noi siamo diventate
poco competenti a capire
che cos'è il femminile.
In realtà non lo sappiamo.
In questo mondo, nel quale abbiamo cercato
di vincere le diseguaglianze,
abbiamo perso il senso delle differenze,
abbiamo fatto un po' una confusione,
perché la diseguaglianza
è una cosa negativa,
diseguaglianza vuol dire la mancanza
di opportunità uguali per le persone,
e uomini e donne hanno diritto
ad avere le stesse opportunità di vita,
di affetto, di lavoro,
ma nonostante questo sono differenti.
L'uomo e la donna
sono profondamente differenti
e questa è una cosa di cui abbiamo perso,
in qualche modo, la consapevolezza.
Vi faccio degli esempi.
A me capita spesso
di vedere coppie giovani,
io come psicoterapeuta vedo
persone singole ma vedo anche coppie
e mi accorgo di questo:
la maggioranza delle coppie giovani, oggi,
arrivano alla vita insieme
in maniera molto più paritaria
che nel passato.
Quindi ragazzi e ragazze studiano,
si dà per scontato che arrivino tutti
a studiare,
iniziano una vita insieme,
anche nella vita insieme
l'uomo e la donna oggi spesso
sono molto paritari,
perlomeno a un certo livello culturale:
chi arriva a casa prima mette su
la lavatrice, fa da mangiare, fa la spesa,
c'è una grande intercambiabilità
dei ruoli,
per cui ci si fa l'idea di essere uguali,
di non avere differenze.
L'evidenza delle differenze nasce, scoppia
su la prima maternità.
Quando arriva il primo bambino,
immediatamente l'uomo e la donna
fanno l'esperienza della loro differenza
e di quanto questa differenza
sia profonda.
Perché che cosa succede:
quando arriva un bambino,
l'uomo e la donna, la mamma e il papà,
entrano in relazione con la nuova creatura
in un modo che è profondamente differente,
ma non per motivi culturali
o per motivi, come dire, organizzativi,
ma per motivi antropologici.
Quindi quello che io spesso vedo,
che cos'è?
Mi arrivano a volte, coppie che
hanno appena avuto un bambino,
che stanno litigando forsennatamente,
tanto che tanti matrimoni o convivenze
si rompono adesso molto spesso
dopo la nascita del primo figlio.
E trovo donne, spesso, molto scontente,
molto scontente con il loro compagno,
col loro marito.
Cosa è successo.
Succede che la donna oggi
non è preparata a capire
che tipo d'ingaggio sarà la maternità.
Ci si prepara alla nascita
di un figlio pensando
che sia uno degli eventi da organizzare.
Io sento queste giovani mamme,
giovani ragazze,
raccontare come si organizzeranno:
riprenderò il lavoro dopo tre mesi,
dopo quattro mesi,
porterò il bambino al nido, lo lascerò
alla mamma, alla nonna, alla suocera...
sembra tutto ben organizzato.
Poi nasce il bambino e la donna
si accorge che succede qualche cosa
che lei non si aspettava
e si sente fregata.
La piccola creatura che nasce è,
per una donna,
una rivoluzione copernicana
nella sua vita,
le cambia completamente
l'ordine dei fattori,
non riesce più a vivere le cose
come le viveva prima,
ma non essendo preparata a questo
la vive anche come una fregatura.
Vive tutta questa esperienza non tanto
nella sua enorme positività, che c'è.
Io ho avuto sei figli, vi posso dire che
i figli sono tutti una grande positività,
che ce la si può fare, che è molto bello,
però certo,
ogni volta che arriva un figlio,
tu senti che la tua vita in qualche modo
si incastra di più,
quel figlio ti incastra per sempre,
non te lo leverai mai più dai piedi,
perché nel tuo cuore lo spazio
sarà sempre presente.
Allora cosa succede:
lì la donna si arrabbia
perché l'uomo non vive le cose
nello stesso modo,
perché anche il più bravo dei papà,
il più attento dei papà,
nel momento in cui sa che il suo bambino
verrà ben accudito,
che c'è una brava babysitter, che mangerà,
che dormirà, che sarà curato ed è sano,
il papà va a lavorare e si dimentica
del suo bambino.
È normale che sia così e anzi,
devo dire che non è solo normale,
è anche la risorsa del paterno,
del maschile,
che il papà possa dimenticarsi
il suo bambino.
Noi invece cosa facciamo:
noi ritorniamo a lavorare,
e come siamo arrivate al lavoro
pensiamo al nostro bambino,
a cosa fanno le altre persone
che lo curano.
Lo cureranno bene?
Lo cureranno male?
E va sempre male, perché
se lo curano male noi stiamo male,
ma se lo curano bene rischiano,
i nostri bambini,
ad affezionarsi alle babysitter,
alle maestre più di quando
non si affezionino a noi
e pensiamo che perderemo
il primo sorriso,
che perderemo la prima pappa
con il cucchiaino.
Non riusciamo a togliercelo
dalla testa.
Noi, contemporaneamente, pensiamo
al lavoro e pensiamo al bambino.
Questo, però, la donna oggi
lo vive male,
non è pronta a questo,
perché non riusciamo, non siamo abituate,
non siamo ancora mature
per vedere la grandissima opportunità
che invece questo rappresenta
e ne viviamo, invece,
il senso di fregatura.
E questo è spesso, come dire,
motivo di lite dentro le coppie,
quando a volte basterebbe poco aiutare
una donna in questi casi.
Qui ci sono tanti uomini
e qualche piccolo consiglio
ve lo potrei dare.
Io dico sempre ai giovani papà:
lei non deve darsi da fare,
perché cosa fanno gli uomini,
gli uomini sono solutori di problemi, no?
Essendo solutori di problemi, giustamente,
che è una cosa buona,
se la donna dice non so come organizzarmi,
si attivano per l'organizzazione
(Risate)
e propongono soluzioni.
Ogni soluzione che viene proposta
fa arrabbiare sempre di più
e questa è l'esperienza di tutti.
(Applauso)
Guardate che invece è molto semplice.
Il problema degli uomini
è che quando pensano al maschile
e non sanno che il pensiero femminile
è diverso,
perché oggi continuiamo
a essere differenti,
ma non sappiamo più come funziona
questa differenza,
siamo ignoranti sulla differenza.
Allora, il pensiero femminile è diverso.
Quando una donna chiede consiglio,
non vuole un consiglio;
(Risate)
quando una donna chiede aiuto,
non vuole un aiuto.
Cosa vuole una donna? Se voi lo sapete,
funzionerà sempre meglio.
Una donna vuol essere ascoltata.
Cosa vuole una donna quando dice non so
come organizzarmi col bambino?
Vuole che il marito, il compagno,
la guardino con grande attenzione
e le dicano: "Come pensavi di fare?"
(Risate)
E lei dirà: "Lo mando al nido
appena compie tre mesi",
e lui: "Ottimo, bellissima soluzione".
Il giorno dopo lei torna e dice:
"Ci ho ripensato.
Senti, cosa dici se lo diamo
alla mamma da tenere?”
e lui dice: "Meglio d'ieri".
Allora, se voi fate così,
ogni volta che noi vi poniamo
un problema, funziona.
(Risate)
(Applauso)
Il vero problema delle donne
è che vogliono trovare
da sole le proprie soluzioni.
Quindi, io dico, c'è questa differenza,
c'è una differenza che è cruciale,
emerge nel momento in cui nasce un figlio,
lì la vediamo perché la sperimentiamo
tutti questa differenza.
Però se dovessimo dire in cosa consiste
la differenza cruciale
fra il maschile e il femminile,
perché in fondo tante cose non sono differenti,
ma ci sono alcune cose di fondo
che sono differenti.
L'ho osservata, l'ho studiata,
l'ho anche letta,
approfondita in diverse letture.
Per esempio, c'è una scrittrice,
una filosofia che è Edith Stein
che negli anni Trenta ha scritto
delle cose molto belle,
molto profonde sulla donna,
anche se è un linguaggio
che oggi forse ci farebbe
un po' sorridere,
ma nella sua sostanza è
di una grande profondità.
Cosa dice Edith Stein? Dice:
la differenza fondamentale
tra l'uomo e la donna è questa:
- ed è emersa in tutti i discorsi
che ho sentito finora - .
L'uomo è orientato alle cose,
invece l'orientamento fondamentale
della donna
è l'orientamento alla persona.
Quindi la donna, spontaneamente,
si muove, è interessata,
si attiva in relazione all'umano,
alla persona, non alla cosa.
E questo vuol dire che per una donna
anche la cosa ha interesse,
ogni cosa ha interesse, in quanto
ogni cosa serve a una persona.
Questa è una differenza fondamentale.
Noi siamo orientati all'umano,
alla persona.
Lo vediamo in questo che vi ho detto,
ma lo vediamo anche in altro.
Pensiamo anche a cose molto semplici,
molto stupide.
Pensate soltanto a una
delle cose classiche
che è il modo in cui un uomo o una donna
curano o non curano la propria automobile.
Per l'uomo l'automobile è una cosa
che ha un suo valore in quanto oggetto:
lo vuole fatto in un certo modo,
lo vuole bello, lo vuole curato, ecc.
Che cos'è per noi la macchina?
La macchina è un mezzo di trasporto
che ci serve per portare i nostri bambini,
le nostre amiche, le merende; per cui
la nostra macchina è sempre in disordine,
ma non è in disordine perché, come
dicono gli uomini, noi siamo disordinate,
è in disordine perché della macchina
in quanto tale non ci interessa.
Cosa ci interessa?
È una cosa utile
in funzione di una persona,
in funzione delle persone.
Questa cosa ha delle ricadute enormi
da tanti punti di vista.
Questa modalità differente, che è
una grande ricchezza,
ci rende molto concrete,
molto concrete, perché per noi
è la vita ciò che conta,
è la vita il motore delle cose,
per cui una donna legge diversamente
tempi, modi, situazioni
per via di questo suo orientamento
di fondo,
quando è in grado di seguirlo,
quando lo percepisce dentro di sé,
quando non lo nega.
Per esempio: la donna legge
in maniera diversa dall'uomo il tempo.
Noi
– sì, sentivo parlare prima del tempo –
per noi il tempo non è
il tempo dell'orologio,
per noi il tempo è il tempo delle persone,
per cui spesso siamo in ritardo,
non siamo puntuali,
ma perché dobbiamo dedicare tempo
alla persona secondo quanto lo richiede.
Oppure, per noi la legge è per l'uomo,
non è l'uomo per la legge.
Tutte le cose, per le donne,
sono orientate all'uomo.
Il tempo è per l'uomo e non viceversa,
la legge è per l'uomo e non viceversa.
Un altro studioso, Lacan,
uno psicanalista del secolo scorso,
diceva che la donna
non è mai tutta nella legge.
Ed effettivamente la donna vive la legge
diversamente dall'uomo,
perché ha sempre in mente la persona
alla quale la norma, la regola, la legge è rivolta.
Vedete quante differenze.
Noi siamo diverse, per esempio,
anche nel mondo di pensare.
Il nostro pensiero è diverso
dal pensiero maschile,
è un pensiero più circolare,
è un pensiero che va meno
dritto sull'obiettivo,
è un pensiero che riflette
a cerchi concentrici,
è un percorso, mi viene da dire,
gestativo, gestazionale:
ci deve crescere dentro
finché è maturo e allora nasce.
Io ho scritto dei libri e ogni volta che
devo scrivere un libro io funziono così:
giro con un quadernetto
dentro la mia borsa e c'è un'idea,
un'idea qualsiasi che mi ha colpito,
ogni tanto mi fermo
perché mi viene un pensiero
e lo metto lì, e poi lo metto lì
e poi lo metto lì,
finché a un certo punto è come
se girando intorno alle cose
la creatura si fosse quasi formata
e quando è pronta la facciamo nascere.
E poi la mandiamo nel mondo.
Abbiamo bisogno di questa circolarità
anche nel nostro pensiero.
Quindi io credo che questa differenza
tra l'uomo e la donna
sia un qualche cosa di sostanziale,
che ha un grandissimo valore.
Qual è il problema? Il problema
è che noi viviamo in un mondo
che non ci aiuta né a conoscere
né a valorizzare questo aspetto di noi.
Allora, forse la sfida è proprio
quella di ritrovarlo,
perché il ritrovare questo modo di pensare
potrebbe rappresentare
una grande rivoluzione
dal basso del mondo femminile,
aiutato naturalmente da leggi
che ci aiutano sulle pari opportunità,
da tutto quello che serve,
ma siamo noi le prime a dover cambiare,
perché finché le donne stanno nel mondo
al modo degli uomini
non possono dare il proprio specifico dono
al mondo.
Credo anche che valga la pena
qui ricordare una cosa
che diceva sempre Lacan.
Lacan diceva:
"Le donne si contano una per una".
Questo è molto bello, nel senso
che le donne sono,
ciascuna a suo modo, un prototipo.
Nessuna di noi è uguale all'altra.
Quindi io credo che la vera libertà
delle donne
non sia quella di omologarsi
al progetto femminile,
tutte devono lavorare, tutte devono stare
a casa, tutte devono fare il part-time,
ciascuna deve costruire
il proprio progetto intorno a sé.
Come un vestito, non c'è un vestito
che va bene a tutte,
noi dobbiamo costruire ciascuna
il nostro vestito
sentendoci, direi, autorizzate a farlo,
perché il vero problema oggi
non è che non desideriamo fare ciascuna
il nostro progetto,
è che stiamo in un mondo che
non ci fa sentire autorizzate a farlo.
Il mondo ci fa sentire
sempre insufficienti.
Noi corriamo più di tutti perché tutte noi
corriamo più degli uomini,
tutte noi facciamo tante cose,
vogliamo coprire tutti i compiti,
ci sentiamo sempre inadempienti
e non ci sentiamo autorizzate a costruirci
un vestito sulla nostra misura.
Io credo che se ci fosse questa capacità
da parte nostra
di prendere il coraggio di guardare
al nostro femminile, di approfondirlo,
di farci la pace, di andarci d'accordo,
noi diventeremmo anche
delle migliori compagne degli uomini,
perché oggi una delle cose
che più mi addolora
è vedere come le donne spesso
siano cattive con gli uomini.
La donna che spontaneamente è orientata
alla persona, dentro di sé,
è diventata oggi,
nel nostro tipo di mondo,
spesso estremamente poco
accogliente e capace
di amore, vicinanza, affetto, perdono,
per l'uomo che spesso le sta vicino.
Allora io credo che ci voglia il coraggio
di ritrovare questa nostra capacità.
Grazie.
(Applauso)